this month marks 20 years since the
death of Princess Diana National
Geographic is marking the anniversary
with a new book called remembering Diana
a life in photographs
it has also produced a new documentary
Diana in her own words the movie
features audio from secret interviews
Diana recorded in 1991 we have a clip
you will see first on CBS this morning
where she discussed an early encounter
with her future husband Prince Charles
I'm coming to all thought to stay became
the Labrador my sister was all over him
like a bad fashion God he must really
hate that
and I kept out of the way I remember
being fat pudgy non makeup and smart
lady but I've made a lot of noise and
like that
and just came up to me after dinner we
had a big dance he said will you show me
the gallery was 1604 someone likes
showing attend she was just so such as
amazed why would anyone let him be
interested in me
[Music]
journalist editor and Diana biographer
Tina Brown has written the foreword to
remembering Diana she also wrote the
book the Diana Chronicles and she joins
us here good morning good morning it is
on it's unbelievable to hear her voice
after so many years everybody I think of
a certain generation feels the same way
about August 31 1997 the way the
previous generation thought about the
assassination of President Kennedy
you knew her what was she like well in
person she was so much more beautiful
than in her photographs that's really
the Stein thing because she had this
really long tall imposing height which
you don't really get a feeling of in the
pictures plus these enormous eyes which
were just big limpid pools of feeling
and then this apricot skin that was the
perfect English rose
so the combination of the dazzling eyes
the peach skin you know and the height
it was really very stunning do you have
any problems with the release of all
these tapes well I think the Morton
tapes that you hear on the National
Geographic are absolutely fair to
release because after all she wanted
those published you know they were they
did form the basis of the book that was
then published by Andrew Morton but was
really Diana's own story that she gave
him the Peter settlin tapes which are
her speech coach which the other
documentary has released they were like
therapy tapes that she was doing in
private I think those should have been
released to her family I think just
simply put on air for anyone to hear her
darkest deepest saddest moments which
were really told in confidence to her
coach and who was really her therapist
as well I think that's really very cruel
to the family why do you think they were
released well for the reason that
everything's released which is for money
it's that plain and simple you don't
think there's a public right to know
when it comes to these kind of details I
think it's still too raw for that to be
seen I would have preferred for them to
wait another ten year
that except for her children and her
philanthropic efforts
did she really know happiness I think
was very hard for da never to be happy
because you know she came from such a
wounded broken family you know her
mother left when she was seven and what
people also forget her grandmother sided
with her father against her mother in
the divorce case so this family was kind
of riven with painful feuds she was the
sort of lonely child in the middle while
the other kids are off at school and
little brother with her so she was a
terribly damaged girl and I think that
the same time you know the whole world
was in love with her everyone was in
love with her except her husband and
that was another sense of rejection I'm
not a sense of rejection so here's this
girl with a primal wound of our family
who then married someone who she thinks
is my princess come and I'm forever
happily forever after only to find it's
like some nightmare you know Fanny by
Gaslight he's actually always been in
love with somebody else
Camilla parker-bowles so the question
obviously is why did he marry her and
who forced him to marry her
well in a way you know what is really
sad for Dioner I think is that everyone
was in on the story except her I mean
this was really an arranged marriage you
know she was picked out by the Queen
Mother and who said look Charles needs
to get married this girl is very young
she's a virgin which is pretty much a
vanished species in the UK at that point
there's no backstory here she's perfect
the Queen and Prince Philip said yes she
is you're right on you know she's
perfect we need to get him married
because he's having an affair with this
married woman Camilla parker-bowles we
don't want that
you know another abdication drama in the
monarchy so everybody was all ganged up
and Charles was sort of too weak to sort
of resist it he knew he had to get
married and he kind of talked himself
into thinking that he could love her but
he was already committed motional II to
somebody else Camilla
and you know really back of his mind he
always knew he could go back to his
mistress because that's what Prince of
Wales always had done diana thought I'm
in a love match here right oh she was
like the only one who didn't know
it's interesting you wrote about Diana
what Diana always possessed even at her
youngest and shiz was an uncanny grasp
of how to play the press there was that
very famous picture which is in this
book of her sitting in front of the Taj
Mahal this goes to what you're talking
about the fact that she knew that her
husband was in love with somebody else
and the
of course that was sort of a signal to
the press dinah was brilliant at using
the press to send her signals to send
her statements out to the world I mean
she really knew how to do that and it
was a kind of intuitive skill she had
from the very beginning and another
reason really why Prince Charles married
her at the beginning was that the press
fell in love with her you know and he
was so used to having bad press about
girlfriends and things Wow you know this
young girl knows how to handle the press
they all love her so it was very
important for a whole question of how
she knew how to play the press of course
later became a lethal skill at court you
know from Charles's point of view
because she always knew much better than
he how to dole out the quick sound bite
the little off-the-record interview or
whatever it was gonna make him look bad
and she played that to the hilt I have
to get the impression from her kids that
they really adored her and she's a very
good mother they did adore her she know
she really that was the biggest gift she
brought to the royal family which was
that having had such a painful
upbringing herself she really was a
wonderful mother you know she was a warm
mother a modern mother a contemporary
girl who knew how to raise her boys to
have a fun rough-and-tumble time taking
them to theme parks taking with him a
dog you got to speak to them - yeah and
I mean she knew how to speak to them and
as a result they come over now as a very
modern young man they like soccer they
know how to you know be modern and speak
to today's youth which was not true of
course of Prince Charles who had been
raised by governesses in a very
Victorian atmosphere these boys went to
boarding school you know and they you
know had to muck it along with everyone
else great to see you Dean I love the
one anecdote you right there where when
she's confronted by the royal family and
she says excuse me but my title has much
more history than yours so direct that
was habits of her great strengths she
was grounded in the royal family yeah
Tina Brown thank you thank you